Nearly every
avenger spilled blood in the battle over
Earth, In the aftermath,
some were sent in to collect that DNA,
Which is probably where he got the idea
for the Super Skrull machine.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This will be my full
Marvel Secret Invasion Episode 5 video.
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references
A couple of cameo scenes too,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
There's
only one episode left to episode six.
The finale will be next week.
careful for spoilers from the episode.
If you haven't seen it yet,
we'll just start at the beginning
and work our way through. Shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the title
Harvest, which is a reference
to the Avengers DNA samples.
The Gravik thinks Nick
Fury has hoping to use them to give all
the Super Skrulls
copies of all the most powerful Avengers
abilities, making them nearly invincible,
claiming that they harvested
a bunch of the Avengers DNA
from the final battle in Avengers Endgame.
We'll see if that isn't a misdirect.
Like Nick Fury claims
that he has the harvest in.
He got it.
But it might wind up being a misdirect
just to get close to gravity.
why would Nick Fury
keep something that dangerous lying around
My early theory
is that he probably destroyed
all the samples
after he had all the Skrulls collect them.
In the aftermath of the Battle of Avengers
Endgame, suddenly,
all the Iron Man truth was like,
We have his DNA.
Let's clone
Iron Man. Let's bring him back That way.
the actual opening scene.
Basically picks up in the moments
right after the end of last week's episode
with him taking the president
to the hospital while trying to tell him
that Rhodey really is a Skrull, hoping
that the president can still hear him
like he's on the edge of death,
posting up in front of the operating room
when you rewatch the episode
now you kind of wonder
when Skrull, Rhodey or Rhodey,
however you want to think about him,
when he's talking to the president,
trying to get him to attack Russia.
Don't you wonder now if the president
really knows that he's or believes
it is a Skrull in it
just leading Rhodey along
until he actually does something
to try and get rid of him.
it's kind of like knowing that Rhodey
has been a skrull for a while
and going back
and watching the old Marvel movies
in new context, like watch his old scenes
in those previous Marvel movies wondering
if he's a skrull in this moment.
you noticed on the news broadcast,
they're talking about the attack
with Talos as if it's a huge revelation.
The world had no idea that
the Skrulls existed before this,
calling him a shapeshifting alien.
There've been a couple reveals
during the series where you kind of
wonder like, Wait a minute,
they're just finding out about this now.
Like, wouldn't
some of the other Avengers characters
have known some of these secrets
before Now?
my assumption
when it comes to stuff like that,
like who knew what
and when did they know it?
Is that Black Widow, for instance?
Probably knew more
than some of the other Avengers,
but a lot of the Avengers
probably knew the truth about the Skrulls.
like Iron Man
probably would have figured out
about the Skrulls with all the stuff
he was doing around the world,
like his access to information
just in general.
All of his technology.
when Gravik starts yelling at Pagon.
his second in command about not
stealing what he was supposed to, he's
talking about cool obsidian
severed hand from Avengers Infinity War.
they'll probably finally obtain it
in the finale
and use that to give themselves
enhanced strength and durability,
basically giving them Hulk
like powers in it for making Fantastic
Four references,
because that's basically
what they're doing in the series,
using all these other abilities
as references to the original Super
Skrulls powers in the comics,
which are based on the fantastic
Four Powers.
Cool Obsidian would be the reference
to the thing Ben Grimm's Powers.
They make it seem like gravity
hasn't killed Nick Fury yet
because he's the only person on the planet
who knows where the Avengers harvested,
DNA is stored.
The harvest itself, and
that would make them nearly invincible.
Not just Thor's DNA, for instance,
but like Spider-Man powers,
Captain Marvel's powers, Scarlet Witch's
powers, Real Hulk, gamma powers,
if we're talking about powers, the Hulk
would be way stronger than the thing.
in the funny thing about this is already
a storyline in the MCU with Hulk
and she holds DNA that they'll pay off in
Captain America for when Thunderbolt Ross
becomes president of the United States
replacing President Ritson in this
or is still going to answer the question
about why that winds up happening
it also winds up using the leader
who's coming back in the movie
from the Incredible
Hulk film to give him Red Hulk powers
Then he ordered Skrull Rhodey
to blame the attack on the Russians,
but also making it seem
like the Skrulls are helping them,
trying to get the president to attack
Russia and start World War three,
thinking that if they don't,
the Skrulls will help the Russians
take over the rest of the planet.
one of the other big reveals
during this scene too,
is that Skrull roadies real name
is actually Rava, which reminds me
of Legend of Korra in Avatar
The Last Airbender with Rava in Vodou.
Maybe there's a skrull out there
somewhere who's also named Fatu,
giving themselves Super Skrull abilities
to bend the four elements
Fire, wind, water and Earth.
we actually just got a trailer
for the new Netflix live action
Avatar, The Last Airbender series.
So I'll post
a link in the description below
and I'll do new videos for the new Avatar,
The Last Airbender,
animated episodes in animated movies.
When they start releasing
those two in the next couple of years.
but Graviks whole plan here
is to get Nick Fury to capitulate to help
them or to stop trying to prevent them
from taking over the planet.
because of all the collateral damage
that will wind up happening.
And the idea
that a lot of the other humans
that they have stored at that Russian base
will also wind up dying in there.
All world
leaders, really important people.
So not only does
Nick Fury want to save all the real people
and bring them back to,
he also wants to save the good skrulls.
that's what Gravik was talking about
when he said
we need to prepare
for the sacrifice, quote unquote,
the collateral damage
and all the dead Skrulls
that will wind up being killed
when the U.S.
attacks Russia.
Also the idea that if they really do
successfully set off World War three
and The Avengers really do assemble again,
it will cause the destruction
of most of their race.
the thing about this is bad
as these seem so far,
even Skrull Rhodey seems like
he has his doubts about the plan.
The Gravik's on people
are starting to turn against him slowly.
Nick Fury then confronts
Brody trying to out and which he can't do
without killing him in reveals
they've released
footage of Gravett killing Maria Hill.
The news outlets around the world
turning Nick Fury into enemy number one.
suddenly,
he knows what it's like to be Spider-Man
with the entire world
coming for your blood.
in now, Jonah Jamison has something
to yell about besides Spider-Man.
But I am sure I am positive
that he will find some way to blame Marie
Hill's death on Spider-Man,
even though the footage clearly shows it
being Nick Fury.
one of Jonah Jameson
super powers is the ability to blame
any situation on Spider-Man no matter
what happened or who was involved.
then we get another cameo scene from Tony
Karon,
who you probably recognize
from a couple other Marvel movies.
He's been in a bunch of other stuff, too.
He's one of Sonia Falls
was my six directors during the series.
They're calling him
Director Weatherby in the credits.
this is now the third Marvel character
that he's played, making it a record.
I think there have been lots of people
who have played
two different Marvel characters,
like Chris Evans was in Fantastic Four
and then he was Captain America.
There are a lot of people
that have done that.
but I don't think a lot of people
have played three characters yet.
before this, he was Finn Cooley
during the Daredevil Netflix episodes,
just a regular human mobster.
And before that he was butcher in Thor,
The Dark World.
Boer was Odin's father in
was king of Asgard before him in the MCU.
the backstory of the Asgardians
is a little bit different in the comics.
The Thor characters
have more of a Game of Thrones.
A back story
that gets way more complicated in Odin
was technically
the founder of Asgard in the comics.
like the comic book
version of Odin is over a million years
old in the one in
the MCU only lived to about 5000 years.
they had a couple of jokes
about these differences
between MCU and comic book continuity
in Thor Ragnarok.
When he was talking to sort of like, did
my father almost kill you
a million years ago or something?
That was a reference to the comic book
backstory of all the characters.
Sonya Bosworth mows
over him to get the information on where
the two doctors that created the super
skull device are so she can find it.
than Betto in the rest of Gravik's team.
Try to pull a cue because they don't
want the collateral damage
that they think this will all cause.
And they think the Graviks' gone crazy.
But because we have seen trailer
footage of Gravik's much later after this,
we know that
he was going to win this fight.
I think the whole idea here is
they want a separate Gravik
from his support system, like his inner
circle, the same way that Nick Fury hasn't
had The Avengers helping him out
the last several episodes.
like it's meant to be a parallel.
There are very few people
that are helping them out,
but for instance, Gravik
still has Skrull Rhodey, Nick Fury meets
Emilia Clarke's guy at that same hideout
that they used back in 1997.
To the flashback, if you couldn't tell.
That's why she says she used to play
underneath this mural
without understanding
what it meant at the time.
Nick Fury makes a bunch of references
to immigrants from World War Two
because the Skrulls are basically
intergalactic immigrants,
saying that he chose this site
because back in World War Two,
this place was a
haven for immigrants from the West Indies.
Then when he starts speechifying to her
about the path of struggle,
it totally gave me Pulp Fiction vibes like
Samuel L Jackson just going on and on.
Really great speeches
there are a couple of good speeches
during this episode.
Like, even though I do have some
criticisms of the way they plotted out
this more TV version of Secret Invasion,
like it has been Avengers level.
He has had a couple good speeches.
she agrees to help protect Varra
from grabbing men
who will give her a special burial
for Talos per the customs of the Skrulls
all explain that in a second, too,
because later in the episode
there are a lot of references to the way
she was raised and how she's forgotten
a lot of the customs of the Skrulls
she also winds up
raking Nick very over the coals
a little bit over her father's death.
And he tries to get her to see that
his death wasn't in vain
and give her the same kind of cold action
that he gave to all the Avengers
characters during phase one.
Phase two, Phase three.
But he's given
a lot of inspirational Avengers speeches.
her reference to putting on a good face
is just another joke about the struggles
shapeshifting abilities.
Sonya falls worth and interrogates
Gravik's doctors
about the Super Skrull device
and kills the male doctor.
She doesn't care about either of them,
but she certainly is one of them.
For more information, though,
she had no problem in killing one of them.
Olivia Colman says
she's been playing the character
kind of like a British version of Val,
but within the context of the MCU,
she's meant to be the daughter
of the original union Jack.
So he's kind of taken the mantle
like Union Jack to.
but the way she's coming off
is sort of like a British version of Val,
like a sinister Mary Poppins.
unlike Val, though,
Sonya falls, word isn't meant to be quite
as bad, like, quite as sinister of a Ben.
But she's not too far off.
She just happens to be working with Nick
Fury like they've been allies in the past.
But it's not like
she has special allegiance to him.
If the world actually broke out in World
War three, she would serve her government.
She would serve the British government
over Nick Fury,
then I think this whole scene
with G'iah over her father, Taylor's
body, is just meant to confirm
that he's dead.
Like comic book
logic, standard comic book rules.
Unless you see a body,
they're not dead in.
They spend a lot of time in this episode
with her
just staring at his lifeless body,
and then they burn the body later
when she enters
Nick Fury's house and passes
all the Greek looking masks on the wall.
I also like the idea that the masks
themselves
are references to all the different faces
that the Skrulls wear like they did.
They could change their faces
when we go back to Skrull, Rhodey
trying to get the president
to attack Rabbit's base,
like I said, I think the idea here is
the President might already suspect
that Rhodey is a screen.
Like maybe he did
Hear what Nick Fury told him.
one of the funny things, though,
because we don't get any more scenes
with him in this episode is that people in
real life asked the actor
if he knew how this was going to end
and what was going to happen to him
that would lead to Thunderbolt Ross
becoming
president in Captain America four.
And he was like, Wait a minute.
That does not bode well for my character.
What happens to me?
Because Marvel apparently didn't give him
the pages for the end of secret Invasion.
They just gave him the pages
for the scenes that he was in meaning
that he is not in the very final scenes
of the episode, which makes sense.
Like this place in post-credits scenes
that set up the Marvel's movie
and the other upcoming Marvel movies.
Gravik
and Nick Fury trade barbs,
telling him to bring the Avengers
DNA samples or it's all going to go down.
And then they have a surprise
cameo from O-T Fagbenle,
who comes back as Mason
from the Black Widow movie.
If you didn't remember,
he's just a mercenary.
Within the context of the MCU,
who's worked with Natasha
Black widow, Yelena Belova,
pretty much all of the others,
like Nick Fury, just getting them weapons,
planes, tech, anything that they needed.
Kind of a less sinister version
of Sharon Carter's power broker character
doing the same type of stuff.
fun fact to super deep
cut in the Black Widow movie,
he was originally secretly
going to be taskmaster.
They hired him with the intention that
that's the character that he was playing,
like he would pretend to be Mason
then really wind up being Taskmaster.
They filmed a bunch of scenes
with this and like,
if you remember all the theories
that came out
when the first couple of trailers dropped,
like, look how tall this person is.
This person is huge compared to Natasha
Black Widow.
It's got to be a man underneath
that costume.
that's because the stunt double
that was wearing the costume
was a man,
and it was meant to be his stunt double.
at some point when they were filming,
the Black Widow would be like,
after a while,
they just decided to pivot on the idea
and make the taskmaster
Dre golfs daughter.
She'll come back
during the Thunderbolts movie.
When Val puts that team together,
they make a joke about the Avengers
helicarrier being mothballed,
another reference to them
not being able to use the Avengers
characters
during the Secret Invasion series.
Like haha, remember
when we had all that cool Avengers stuff?
Yeah. No, we can't use that right now.
Then they have Talos'
special Skrull burial ceremony.
Varra helps G'iah perform traditional Skrull
burial rites, They also use this scene
to show you more of Skrull culture
just in general.
this ring belonged to Taylor's wife, Guy.
His mother, end, I think the whole concept
of G'iah, not knowing how to perform
a traditional Skrull burial ceremony
or the prayer that they're supposed to say
is meant to be a reference
to the phenomenon in real life,
where children of immigrants
who grew up completely in another country,
another culture, don't remember
or never fully learn
the traditions of the original culture
that they came from,
That happens all the time in real life.
So like the idea is the guy has been
living amongst humans for so long,
she's forgotten what it's like to live
as a Skrull or live on Skrullos
so the prayer just in general sounds like
it's kind of like the same burial rites.
The asgardians perform like the Skrulls
have their own version of the afterlife
in their ushering talos
into the Skrull afterlife.
we learned a little bit about the way
this works during the Moon Night series.
Like the afterlife in general
is just an alternate dimension
that people's consciousness goes to
when their physical bodies die.
the dimension that you go to
is just based on your own belief system,
or if you have a contract
with a higher cosmic entity or a God,
you go to the afterlife
associated with that God.
really good example is that New Knight
didn't worship the Egyptian gods
or believe in Egyptian afterlife
like the dude before he died.
But because of his contract with you,
that's where he went after he died.
the during the episode
they just call it the Beyond.
VAR also references her
seeing Talus again.
Eventually she's talking about seeing him
in the afterlife after she dies some day.
There's no hinting that
he'll come back to life.
even though that is possible,
like you can come back to life
as we saw during Moon Knight.
But in order to do it, your physical body
still needs to be intact.
And they just cremated Taylor's body.
So there is no coming back for him.
she also jokes about her last words
to Nick very
before he got snapped in Avengers Infinity
War, saying that she might leave him
if he kept spending so much time away
from their marriage out on missions.
and she reveals the real reason why
she's been sticking around at their house
waiting for Gravik's men to come kill
is because it's incredibly defensible.
You have to remember, we're talking about
Nick Fury and his wife here.
they have contingency plans
upon contingency plans, she has weapons
stashed all over the house,
as you would expect in Nick Fury's house.
They also remind you
that she used to be an agents of shield,
even though
shield itself, most people Inside
Shield didn't know that she was secretly
a skrull.
it's like she has the same combat
training that any of the other Avengers,
like even Black Widow,
would have any of those.
She appears to be very old Skrulls
live extremely long lives.
So technically she's
still pretty young for a Skrull.
Is this the form that she's wearing right
now is of an older woman.
She also reveals that she bought the house
15 years ago, putting it in 2011
because present day
the MCU is meant to be 2026
when this is happening, me that Nick Fury
and her probably bought the house
after the events of the first Thor movie.
But. Part of her joke is that she is
the person who actually found the house
and bought it, hoping
that Nick Fury would settle down with her
there and stop running around the world.
he didn't obviously,
because the first three phases of Marvel
were pretty big, like the Infinity Saga
movies kept him pretty busy.
G'iah also makes a sly Nick Fury masochist
joke, saying that he loves places
with lots of leather,
which is also meant to be foreshadowing
for the end of the episode where he gets
his leather jacket and his eyepatch back.
the argument that they get into though,
over whether or not she spent time
in her own Skrull Natural skin around
Nick Fury is meant to be about compromise.
And I think foreshadowing
for the way in the series
and what happens with the rest
of the Skrulls that are left over,
I think what they're trying to set up here
is the idea
that all the rest of the Skrulls
will get to stay on Earth.
but the compromise for them
is that they'll have to blend in
more with the rest of the humans.
So yes, they can revert to their natural
Skrull form a little bit more.
But for the most part, they still have to
walk around inhuman looking skin.
some of you also remember, too,
that his wife, during
this series also played his mother
during the Unbreakable movies.
So it's a little bit
of a funny association
there just going back
and watching those movies
now, they've a pretty solid action scene.
It's over pretty quickly.
But they defend the house,
as you would expect.
She has weapons
stashed all over the place.
The only thing I was disappointed by
is the demure Clerks guy character didn't
use her extremist Firebase Powers, yet
she's only used the healing power so far.
Hopefully she'll use the fire abilities
before the series is over.
we get another Captain America
Winter Soldier reference.
And you could probably call it a mission
impossible reference too,
because the new Mission
Impossible movie just came out in.
There's a lot of phase switching
in that movie Nick Fury enters Finland.
Wearing a special mask is the same mask
technology that they use in
Captain America Winter Soldier to pretend
to be someone else to get past customs.
they call it the widow's veil because it's
based on Black Widow technology
that Natasha probably helped them develop.
they also wind up revealing
that Sonia Failsworth did not know
Rhodey was a Skrull
and his wife was a Skrull as well
He also explains the details
behind the actual harvesting
of the Avengers DNA and why
it wound up happening in the first place.
The idea is that during the final battle
in Avengers Endgame, all of the Avengers,
even Carol Danvers,
spilled blood, leaving their DNA samples
all over the ground, all over the place.
So when Val Thunderbolt
Ross, other interested sinister
people went in to collect samples,
Nick Fury also sent in his Skrull agents
pretending to be humans
to get the samples before them.
end, I think part of the idea was
he did that to prevent
the samples of the Avengers DNA from
getting into the hands of terrible people.
But the consequence of that is the Gravik
who was on
that team of Skrulls working for Nick Fury
learned about the Avengers DNA
and that gave him the idea to create
super Skrulls Blame it all on Thanos.
In that final battle in Avengers Endgame.
But that's going to be the major reason
why Nick Fury feels responsible
for the entirety of secret invasion.
He's at least partially responsible
for breaking his promise
to find them a new planet to live on.
Carol Danvers, Captain Marvel
also kind of responsible for that to
and for giving Gravik
the whole idea to create super skrulls.
He also makes it sound like
if this hadn't happened,
like if secret invasion Gravik's plan
hadn't started,
he would still be on that saber space
station.
He never would have come to Earth
in the first place.
Then he explains why his grave here is
in Finland is because he and his wife
Vera, had their honeymoon here because
Skrulls, like the cold, also revealing
to so many false work that his wife is
a Skrull It's meant to be him.
Trying to explain to Sonya Bosworth
that some of the skrulls are good people
because her whole thing in the past
couple of episodes has been trying
to find a reason to kill all Skrulls
that's what Talus was worried
about at the beginning of the series.
Like, if we don't stop her,
she'll kill all the skrulls on the planet.
he also jokes that he has gravestones
like this all over the planet
because a man needs options.
We have secret weapons, stashes, supplies,
all over the world, as you would expect.
I mean, we're talking about Nick Fury
here.
Nick Fury also winds up
referencing his mother and his wife.
Also the fact that he grew up
without a father
like a little bit
more of Nick for his backstory.
They've been using the series
to tell you a bunch about his backstory
they make another
Avengers reference with her asking why
he hasn't called The Avengers to help him.
Like, you're special friends.
The real reason, obviously, is budget,
the series cost them over
$200 million to make that doesn't
feel like a $200 million series.
But I think part of the reason for that
is inflation caused by the pandemic
and some of the special protocols
in filming TV series and movies right now.
Kevin five, he said, when they started
making the Marvel Disney Plus series,
they wanted to keep the budget closer
to like $150 million.
this is also part of the reason
why Marvel is stretching out.
The release is so much like when they said
they're not doing as many Disney
Plus series for Marvel or Star Wars stuff.
What they meant
is that they're just doing them
less frequently,
mostly because they're super expensive.
There's still a bunch of stuff
coming later this year,
like we have Loki season two episodes,
we have the X-Men episodes
that will start at the beginning
of next year.
Don't worry,
I'll do videos for all that stuff.
When we get new trailers for everything.
when he grabs the vial of Avengers
DNA, though, like I said earlier,
don't
you think this is meant to be a misdirect
and there's no actual Avengers
DNA in there?
like,
why would he actually have Avengers DNA
that he would take to that Russian base
if it weren't a big fake out?
The other thing here, too, talking
more about Marvel Phase seven and beyond
with X-Men characters,
Sonya Falls, we're talking about Darwin.
She's talking about Charles Darwin
in the concept of evolution.
you can also call this
a reference to the concept of mutants
in X-Men, in the MCU, Homo Superior,
the next evolution of humanity already
having sorted like Kamala Khan was born
a mutant in the MCU.
pretty soon we'll start seeing way
more mutants showing up in the MCU.
that's probably what they'll use
the next big saga of Marvel movies for.
Like we're in the middle of the multiverse
saga after Avengers six Secret Wars.
When we start Marvel Phase seven,
they'll probably have the Mutant saga
everybody hearing them
play the theme song in their head.
he gets his trademark
leather jacket and eyepatch back,
looking more like the OG Nick Fury.
This is just meant to be like
the Avengers level.
Nick Fury coming back like,
All right, shits on
and it winds up being one of the shortest
episodes of the series so far.
Like, it's pretty quick, there are
a couple major hanging plot threads.
They have to resolve
in the finale next week.
What happens to Gravik
Like does Nick Fury wind up killing him?
Because it does seem like
he gets way more supernatural powers.
What happens to the rest of the Skrulls?
I already talked about that.
I think it'll be a compromise,
quote unquote,
and they'll continue
getting to live on Earth.
What happens to President Ritson
that leads Thunderbolt Ross becoming U.S.
president by the events of Captain America
four in How did they end things in a way
that set up the Marvel's movie
like a post-credits
scene with Captain Marvel cameo scene,
or a monica Rambeau cameo scene with him
going back to the Saber Space station?
Generally, there's still a ton of stuff
that they have to wrap up.
Let me know in the comments
what kind of a post-credits scene
you're expecting, though?
If you did spot any Easter eggs
or references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
my Episode 6 finale Trailer Video
We'll post on Thursday
in my full episode 6 video we'll post
next week after they release it.
remember too.
This weekend is Comic-Con will probably
only get a couple of Comic-Con trailers.
Like, I think we'll get a new Marvel's
trailer pretty soon.
A new Invincible Season two trailer,
maybe some Loki season
two footage pretty soon,
Whatever they wind up releasing,
even though there's not a big Marvel Hall
H panel, I'll do videos for it.
Don't worry.
click here for that Secret Invasion
Episode 6 Finale Video.
Update the link as soon as I post
that and click here for my new Deadpool
3 video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!